[Music]
well delighted to have you here thank
you for coming up I'm looking forward to
this conversation for a long time is we
just sort of spoke a moment ago
everything that you're about the work
that you do is definitely right in the
sweet spot of the things that I'd love
to talk about I think the work you're
doing is important and I'm excited to
dig into it with her eyes
woody what are you doing here in LA well
I'm here for one reason that I'm not
allowed to talk about because it's not
been announced yet so I have to be
slightly mysterious but also I was here
to do I was at politic on you know the
weird political convention happens here
so I was debating addiction with Chris
Christie the disgusting former governor
of New Jersey and dr. drew so that was
when exactly call it fun but it was
intriguing that's interesting I'm
familiar with dr. Drew's opinions on it
but where does where does Chris Christie
fall but Christie pretends to be you
know in favor of distinct motivation but
he got very angry when I asked him so he
keeps saying you know I'm against stigma
against people with addiction problems
but he's not in favor of changing the
laws and I said well the laws
criminalized drug use and drug addiction
provide genesis of the stigma exactly do
you is at least a significant expression
of the stigma so I kind of said to him
do you see any contradiction there how
do you how do you reconcile them and he
just did his kind of sob Soprano shtick
which does good body I'm from New Jersey
you don't get to bully me
he just didn't to have a serious
discussion about it and what about dr.
drew honestly I just didn't think he
understood quite basic things about
addiction he seemed like a very nice
person but he didn't really understand
you know the debate about the opioid
crisis cussing the opioid crisis the
debate about the opioid crisis in the
u.s. is so removed from really basic
facts about even what addiction is
they're not critical of people for that
before I started doing the research for
my book chasing the screen which is
about addiction and the drug war I don't
think I didn't understand many of these
basic things as well I don't think dr.
drew really
I think both Chris Christie and dr. Drew
were making the mistake I don't want to
over ascribe this to doctor I think he's
a bit more sophisticated than this
certainly most particular thing chris
Christie
but just making a basic mistake about
what why this crisis is happening right
so if you'd asked me when I started
doing the research for chasing The
Scream and if it was eight years ago now
what causes addiction let's say heroin
addiction because that played out in
people I loved and I would looked at you
like you're an idiot and I would have
said well obviously heroin causes Herron
addiction right we've been told this
story for a hundred years about
addiction that's become totally part of
our common sense one of my earliest
memories is of trying to wake up what am
i relatives are not being able to I
didn't understand why then as I got
older I realized we have drug addiction
in my family and and so when we I
thought about saying like heroin
addiction obviously I thought you know
we're sitting here in ink you know in
Los Angeles we think if I grabbed the
next 20 people to walk past your house
and I injected them all with heroin
every day for a month like a villain in
a Saw movie at the end of that month
they'd all be heroin addicts for a
simple reason
this chemical hooks in heroin their
bodies would start to desperately
physically need they'd have this
desperate physical craving they'd be
hooked that's where we get the phrase
hooked from and that's what addiction is
right that's what I thought I'd happened
in my family that's what I thought I'd
seen happen in front of me and I only
learned that while there's some truth in
that story it's actually a small part of
the story and that there's something
much bigger and more important going on
when I went to Vancouver and interviewed
this amazing man caught Professor Bruce
Alexander so professor Alexander
explained to me and this story we've got
in our heads the addiction is caused
primarily by the chemical hooks and the
drug comes from a series of experiments
that were done earlier in the 20th
century they're really simple
experiments your listeners can try them
at home if they feel a little bit
sadistic you take a rap you put it in a
cage and you give it two water bottles
one is just water and the other is water
laced with either heroin or cocaine if
you do that the rap will almost always
prefer the drugged water and almost
always kill itself quite quickly so
there you go right that's our story but
in the 70s professor Alex
two came along and said well hang on a
minute you put the rap alone in an empty
cage which got nothing that makes life
meaningful for rats what would happen if
we did this differently so he built
occasionally called rat Park which is
basically like paradise for rats right
they've got loads of friends they can
have loads of sex they got as a cheese
and colored balls and wheels of anything
that makes life meaningful to rats it's
there in rat Park and they've got both
the water bottles the normal water and
the drugged water but this is the
fascinating thing in rat Park that I'd
like the drugged water they almost never
use it none of them ever use it
compulsively none of them ever overdose
so you go from almost 100% compulsive
use of overdose when they don't have the
things that make life meaningful to none
when they do there's loads of human
examples we can talk about this but to
me the core lesson of this is the
opposite of addiction is not sobriety
important though that is to many people
the opposite of addiction is connection
and having your psychological needs met
and I think we need to understand the
opioid crisis in that context right it's
not a coincidence that the opioid crisis
is at its most intense in the place
where the non-oil opioid based suicide
rate is highest where antidepressant
prescriptions are highest that tells us
something it does despair clusters
together right there's a leading
economist who's called opioid deaths
despair deaths whereas it seemed to me
dr. Drew and Chris Christie were chris
Christie exclusively and dr. drew way
too much we're focusing on the drug
itself right now the drug itself plays a
role there are chemical hooks they do
they can cause physical dependence but
and neglecting much more so for example
you know I think that the core of
addiction is about not wanting to be
present in your life because your life
is too painful a place to be once you
understand that you can see why the drug
war imposing more pain and more
punishment on people it's such a
disaster right because it causes more
pain it makes actually deepens the
addiction so I was very disturbed by
that chris Christie is a supporter of
the drug war he's in favor of punishment
I mean he says over will will make the
prisons nice treatment centers for some
people rather than just brutal prisons
but still a criminal you're still
criminalizing people stigmatizing them
and the drug treatment centers he wants
to put in the press
not so impressive either and dr. Dre was
still saying things like well we need to
impose negative consequences you know
that that can be helpful for some people
that is not helpful that there's nowhere
in the world that is reduced addiction
through imposing negative consequences
is your friend of mine dr. Gabriel
Montes said it said to me once the
negative consequences stopped addiction
there wouldn't be a single addict
anywhere in the world because what
negative consequences had they not yeah
I mean listen I agree with everything
that you're saying certainly I think to
be fair to dr. drew he's not gonna be on
Chris Christie's punitive page like he's
he's been very outspoken about the
ability
over punitive measures that he was
saying that there should be he did say
that with some of this is what surprised
I thought this all the negative
consequences for your behavior I think
is I think we're we're we're we're he's
kind of the the space where he's dancing
around is is something I can relate to
which is when you I've heard that you
know I know about that rat study and I
think it's super informative in terms of
getting people to kind of rethink the
paradigm it's very powerful in that
regard but I also think it's it's more
complicated than that it is indeed
certainly true that the compulsion to
use that the addict is coming from a
place of being uncomfortable in their
own skin in their own life whether
that's the result of childhood trauma or
some kind of psychological miss wiring
which we can get into it's it's a
complex you know matrix of many factors
that I think contribute to somebody
becoming an addict versus somebody who's
just a casual user in the case of you
know your heroin example and you know
genetics genetics probably plays a small
role in that some role but in terms of
unpacking that like I know for myself a
long time sober guy when you know my
loved ones fled that was not you know
that was not lost on me like that was
definitely a motivating factor and me
finally reckoning with the damage that
I'd created and ultimately starting to
walk the path towards sobriety so I
think there is some wisdom in in in this
idea of not being complicit
and as they say codependent in an
addicts behavior and I thought one thing
that was striking in your your amazing
TED talk which I loved was this idea of
moving towards the Attic dust as opposed
to away from them this idea that that we
should sing love songs not war songs
with respect to them that we should
bring the addict closer and let them
know that we love them I think that's
important but I also think it's
important to use discernment so that the
addict understands like this is not
acceptable that there is some
conditional aspect to the relationship
that if they do X Y & Z that not
necessarily that you're retracting your
love but that you can't make yourself
available to be a punching bag for that
person's errant ways I mean love doesn't
mean I think you making important points
love doesn't mean giving someone
everything they want in any situation
right you don't love your children by
giving your child candy all the time and
no loving relationship involves just
100% giving the person what they want
and that goes for people with addictions
and people without Rhodesians that's
obviously true and I think one of the
reasons why the debate about the war on
drugs is so charged is because it runs
through the hearts of all of us right
everyone I feel this even now after all
the research I did purchasing the screen
everyone has someone they love who's got
an addiction problem it has a part of
them that thinks god someone should just
stop you why are you being so stupid why
are you being so destructive and then
there's another part that most people
have that is compassionate and says oh
wait a minute this is someone trying to
deal with a very profound sense of pain
they're anesthetize themselves actually
we need to deal with the causes of their
pain yeah because the drug is the
solution not that it's not that it's not
the cause it's not the problem itself
the problem is the person you're left
with when you take the drugs away I
think it's not just a person you're left
with it's the environment the cage
you're left with I mean there's a very
challenging line in Marianne Faithfull's
memoir you know the great British rock
star and she says at one point something
like so she had heroin addiction in the
60s when she was homeless she said um
heroine saved my life because if it
wasn't the heroin I would
killed myself at that point that's a
very challenging thing to hear for a lot
of people that was challenging for me
when I read it
now obviously Marianne Faithfull is not
saying heroin is a good solution to
despair but I do think it's very
important to understand why but let's
think about the opioid crisis right why
is this happening
why it was so many vectors of despair I
mean so think it's serving a need that
is so profound that it outweighs the
negative ramifications of the behavior
there's a really good way of putting it
everyone listening to your show knows
that they have natural physical needs
right obviously you need food you need
water you need shelter you need cleaner
if I took those things away from you
you'd be in real trouble real fast but
as equally strong evidence that all
human beings have natural psychological
needs you need to feel you belong you
need to feel your life has meaning and
purpose you need to feel that people see
you and value you you need to go you've
got a future that makes sense how
culture is good at lots of things I'm
glad to be alive today I love dentistry
I love gay marriages our range of things
but we've been getting less and less
good at meeting these deep underlying
psychological needs and this is
manifesting in just an enormous range of
problems right think about what sort of
someone more recent but lost connections
you know one in three middle-aged women
in the United States at any given time
is taking a chemical antidepressant even
more are depressed and not taking drugs
and the suicide rate combined with
opioid deaths is now so high that white
male life expectancy has fallen for the
first time in the entire peacetime
history of the United States
teenage girls couldn't profess at your
twenties done really good research from
this now have the same anxiety and the
average American teenage girl now has
the same average anxiety level as a
mental patient had in the 1950s right so
we've got this whole vector of despair
these different forms of despair I would
argue the political situation we're in
is a manifestation of profound despair
and anger we need to understand why this
is happening and at the moment I think
we've been offered stories that are too
simplistic so when it comes to the
opioid crisis we'd be offered a story
that's not false the drug companies did
do terrible things
and that they do bear some
responsibility I'm in favor of the
criminal prosecution of Purdue and very
some things for Mis selling their drugs
but that's not the core of why this is
happening right that if we think ain't a
better analogy to help us to understand
it if you think about something that
happened in in Britain in the 18th Sun
British Britain in the 18th century so
at that time huge numbers of people were
driven out of the countryside into these
disgusting urban slums in places like
London and Manchester they lost
everything that have made life
meaningful to them and they're suddenly
totally disorientated in this place they
don't understand and there was a huge
outbreak of alcoholism it was known as
the gin craze and it really did happen
right there's a famous painting from the
time accordion lane of a mother downing
a bottle of gin while her baby falls
over some steps right and there really
was this this crisis really did happen
and if you look at what people said at
the time what they said is look at this
evil drug gin look at what it's done to
us if only we could get rid of this evil
drug Jim we wouldn't have this problem
now when we look back we know it can't
be gin that caused it because anyone in
Britain is over the age of 18 can go and
buy gin it's easier to get gin now than
it was then
and while we still have some alcoholism
of course we don't have mass alcoholism
in the streets we don't have babies
falling out of windows what changed what
changed is not the availability of the
drug what changes the amount of despair
and pain in the society if you want to
understand why people are turning to
painkillers in such enormous numbers we
have to understand why they're in such
pain right I mean people on the faculty
at Harvard have much easier access to
opiate based painkillers the people in
West Virginia who disproportionately
don't have their medical insurance and
yet West Virginia has a drastically
higher level of opioid addiction than
the faculty at Harvard what's going on
it's not access to the drug right it's
terrible terrible deep pain we've
created a culture which for many people
it's not bearable to be present in right
so you think about one false narrative
is the forces are onward one limited
narrative is the opioid crisis is simply
the result of opioids and if only we got
rid of the opioids we'd all be ok again
when in fact what would happen is think
about Marianne Faithfull's quite or what
you're saying they were just that it
would be in some ways better
few people would overdose but there
would be profound despair right well
think about depression so when I was a
teenager I went to my doctor and I
explained that I had this feeling like
pain was leaking out of me and I
couldn't control it
I couldn't regulate it and my doctor
told me a story that again I now
realized was was really oversimplified
my doctor said well we know why people
feel this way there's a chemical called
serotonin in people's brains some people
are just naturally lacking it you're
clearly one of them all you need to do
is take this drug in in this case it
gave me an antidepressant called paxil
you're gonna feel you're gonna be fine
right so start taking the Center
depressant I felt significantly better
for a few months real boost and then
this feeling of pain started to come
back so I went back to my doctor again I
felt better
again this feeling of pain came back and
I was really locked in this cycle of
taking higher and higher doses until for
thirteen years I was taking the maximum
days at the end of which I was still
profoundly depressed and I really felt
haunted by these two mysteries one is me
related to what we're talking about you
know I'm nearly 40 every year that I've
been alive depression and anxiety have
increased in the United States and
across the Western world I don't know
why right if it was just a problem
inside our brains which i think is
simplistic in the way the chemical hoax
story is simplistic about drugs it was
just a problem in our brains why would
it be rising so much it can't just be
that all our brains start to malfunction
at the same time there must be something
deeper deeper going on and so I ended up
going on this big journey all over the
world for lost connections as you know
and I learned that there's kind of
scientific evidence for nine causes of
depression and anxiety two of which are
biological but most of which have
factors in the way we live now yeah it's
interesting that the work that you've
done in addiction and in that that first
book really boils down to an assessment
of how we're living culturally this this
lack of connectivity that we have that
is fueling in large part this increase
in
in a substance addiction across the
board when I and then how you've now
extended that to look at mental
disorders specifically depression and
anxiety and it's it's really the same
thing and in order to really kind of
understand this as we begin to you know
look at these nine reasons which we're
going to get into we have to look we
have to like step back and look at
society you know it's it's like to echo
Henry David Thoreau you know the mass of
men lead lives of quiet desperation and
it's more true now than then ever people
are more disconnected from their fellow
man I know you have that statistic where
I don't know how long ago it was that if
you ask somebody how many good friends
you have that would come to your aid it
was somewhere in the range of five and
now for a lot of people it's zero the
most common is are now when you ask
people how many close friends do you
have you could turn to in a crisis is
none right so there's been this enormous
and this is one of many pieces of
evidence Jose has been in it we are the
loneliest society there's ever been
right there's been this enormous
explosion in loneliness ironic given the
connectivity that the devices we all
carry around in our back pocket you know
provide us with but it's elusive
illusory compared to real connectivity
with another human being and I think
laid on top of this is a system a
cultural priority that this engine that
is driving us to distance ourselves
further and further away from each other
because the mandate is to succeed to get
as much as you can for yourself to live
this life of luxury of convenience and
we have lost sight of what it is that
that truly makes us human in the most
beautiful way which is our relationship
with each other with our families the
networks that we create the connectivity
the cooperation that allowed this
species that you know if you ask you've
all no Harare should have never survived
yet we were able to do so simply because
of this genetic predisposition that we
have to be connected with each other and
that's what we've lost and I think we're
now seeing on a mass epidemic scale the
results of what
when the human being is removed from
that basic requirement that we have in
order to feel contented fulfill
purposeful engage with life and and and
the sense that that the lives that we're
pursuing have meaning it is a crisis of
consciousness it's a spiritual crisis as
much as anything else and it really
boils down to the way that we we've
structured the society in which we live
I think there's a lot of things in we
just said that holy rice so I learned a
lot about this from a man called
Professor John Cacioppo sadly just died
but he was the leading expert on
loneliness in the world he was at the
University of Chicago he explained a few
things to me that were really important
the touch and what you said so he he
talked about he said I'm who saying to
me why are we alive why do we exist one
key reason is that our ancestors on the
savannahs of Africa were really good at
one thing they usually were not faster
than the animals they track down they
usually weren't bigger than the animals
they track now what they were was much
better at banding together into groups
and cooperating so just like bees
evolved to need a hive humans evolved to
need a tribe in fact humans who had
wandered off on their own would have
died out right they were a species
inclined to do that wouldn't would not
continue to exist and actually few think
about those circumstances if you were
separated from the tribe in the
circumstances where we evolved you would
be depressed and anxious for a really
good reason you were probably about to
die
those are the instincts we have right if
you separate a bee from its hive and it
will go crazy look at it it will lose
its mind right it will panic it will
freak out it'll be profoundly distressed
and eventually it will just give up in a
similar way we are the first humans to
ever try to disband our tribes to try to
live alone and this is a disaster for us
a real disaster and one of the things I
wanted to think about is given that as
overwhelming evidence that is a cause of
depression
what is the antidepressant for that
right and I learned one of the heroes in
my book lost connections is this amazing
man called dr. Sam evring t'en who's a
doctor in East London right a poor part
of East London where I lived for a long
time
and Sam was really uncomfortable because
like me he thinks there's some role for
chemical antidepressants but he was just
very conscious of two things firstly
most of the people he was given chemical
antidepressants too were becoming
depressed again it was getting a bit of
relief and secondly they were depressed
the perfectly good reason so you know
one of the nine causes that we're
talking about here is lost connection
it's our ease loneliness and so one day
he decided to pioneer a different
approach a woman came to see him who I
got to know quite well with Lisa
Cunningham and Lisa had been shut away
in our home with just crippling
depression and anxiety for seven years
as Sam said to Lisa don't worry I'm
going to carry on giving you this drug
I'm also going to prescribe something
else there was an area behind the
doctor's surgery that was known as
[ __ ] alley which gives you a sense of
what it was like it's just the kind of
scrubland and Sam said to Lisa what I'd
like to do is come and turn out a couple
of times a week I'm going to come to
because I've been quite anxious and with
a group of other depressed and anxious
people we're going to turn dog sure Ally
into something nice right the first time
the group man Lisa was literally
physically sick with anxiety but they
decided this group that they were gonna
learn gardening right there were
inner-city East London people like me
and then I don't thing about gardening
right that is they started to get their
fingers in the soil they started to
learn the rhythms of the seasons and but
any more important things started to
happen they began to by the way I should
say about like there's loads of evidence
that exposure to the natural world
is a really powerful engine with nature
and connection with others exactly they
started to form a tribe they started to
form a group they started to care about
each other they started to solve each
other's problems they started to notice
if one of them didn't show up and go and
check on them the way Lisa put it to me
as the garden began to bloom we began to
bloom it was a study in Norway of a very
similar program that found it was more
than twice as effective as chemical
antidepressants I think for an obvious
reason it was dealing with some of the
reasons why they were depressed and
anxious in the first place this is
something I saw all over the world from
Sao Paulo to Sydney to San Francisco the
best strategies for dealing with this
epidemic of despair this depression this
anxiety this addiction are the ones that
deal with the reasons why we feel like
this in the first place mm-hmm yeah it's
it's interesting
I feel like we're seeing this trend of
people like yourself that are coming out
and looking at problems that we that
we're experiencing as a culture as human
beings that we have traditionally
treated in a certain way and that way
being kind of part and parcel of the
Gestalt of the scientific method
producing less and less beneficial
results and then now we're kind of
looking in the rearview mirror and
saying hold on I know we all think this
is working but it's actually not working
so well why don't we look back through
history and see how we've dealt this
dealt with these problems as a species
in the past and realizing that there's a
lot of wisdom there that we've
overlooked we like to think that we've
transcended you know these primal needs
that we can live in these hermetically
sealed environments that we can drive
around in air conditioning and we can
you know do what we do and be perfectly
fine and pop a pill if we feel less than
stellar and that's the end of the story
when in fact in order to really fully
redress this we need to look at it
holistically and understand that it's
not one thing it's not a constant or a
variable that we can just tweak but we
need to really reassess how we're
fundamentally living and you know in
every aspect of that I think that's a
really good way of putting it you know
the Indian philosopher Krishnamurti said
it's no sign of good health to be well
adjusted to a sick society and if you
are uncomfortable and distressed in a
world where Donald Trump is the most
powerful person that's not a sign that
you're crazy that's a sign that you're
saying and I think it's important to
think about this so this there's there's
there's extremely strong scientific
evidence that there are three kinds of
cause of depression and anxiety and to
some degree they play out in in in fact
all forms of mental and emotional
problems so there's biological cause is
like your genes like real brain changes
that happen when you become depressed
that can make it somewhat harder to get
out those are real right there are
people who deny them they are
Atlee wrong the evidence is very clear
on that there are psychological causes
which are how you think about yourself
and there are social causes which are
how we live together and these are all
real but what we've done is we've
largely as a culture told a story that
focuses exclusively on the biology right
you think about what my doctor told me
there's just a problem in your brain the
problem with that well the first problem
that is not true right but the second
problem that is what it tells people is
your distress doesn't mean anything it's
like a glitch in a computer program and
somebody really helped me to think a bit
differently about this I went to
interview this South African
psychiatrist called Derrick Sommerfeld
he's a wonderful man and he happened to
be in Cambodia in 2001 when they
introduced chemical in situ process for
the first time - for the people in that
country and the local doctors the
Cambodian doctors had never heard of
these drugs so they were like why are
they and he explained and they said oh
we don't need them we've already got
antidepressant and he said what do you
mean he thought they were going to talk
about some kind of herbal remedy like
sand john's wort or something instead
they told him a story there was a farmer
in their community who one day stood on
a landmine and got his leg blown off and
he worked in the rice fields so they
gave him an artificial limb and he went
back to work in the rice fields after I
forget what it was some months but
apparently it's very painful to work
underwater with an artificial leg I'm
guessing it was traumatic for obvious
reasons the guy started to cry all day
didn't want to get out of bed develop
classic depression they said to dr.
something well that's when we gave him
an antidepressant and he said wow they
explained that they went and sat with
him they listened to him they realized
that his pain made sense they figured if
they bought him a cow he could become a
dairy farmer he wouldn't be in this
position that was screwing him up so
much so they bought him a cow with a
couple of weeks as crying stock within a
month his depression was gone they said
to dr. Sommerfeld so that cow that was
an antidepressant that's what you mean
right now if you've been raised to think
about this the way we have that sounds
like a joke I went to my doctor for an
antidepressant he gave me a cow but what
those Cambodian doctors knew intuitively
is what the leading medical body in the
world the World Health Organization has
been trying to tell us for years if
you're depressed if you're anxious
you're not crazy
you're not a machine with broken parts
you're a human being with unmet needs
and what you need is practical love and
support from the people around you to
get those deeper needs met it's a very
different way of talking about these
problems it explains to people that pain
is a signal it means something evolved
for a reason is telling you your needs
aren't being met or some other things
that obviously reference to a by there's
some you know psychological event that
occurred that you haven't really fully
processed or worked through there's some
there's some hitch in your operating
system that that requires redress and I
wouldn't say operating system
experiencing the grief in the law and
the loss of a loved one or something
like like yes there are natural
reactions that you know we've kind of
been told we should just get over that
kind of stuff rather than really just
embrace them for what they are because
that is that is what it is to be human
and that's certainly fine and to
stigmatize that or just to kind of
pathologize that as certain is certainly
wrong but they're there their messages
their wake-up calls that if their signal
yeah yeah you need to do that and I
think to go back to the cultural piece
you know someone's grieving the loss of
a loved one and they're uncomfortable
sitting with that grief we have a system
that's set up to help you and say you
don't need to feel this way like take
this take this pill right because we've
gotten to a place where it's almost
understood that we never need to feel
bored or uncomfortable or ill at ease
right that we can that we can just
medicate all of that and and implicit in
that is this idea that we should all be
happy all the time I think people are
right to want to be happy and satisfied
in their lives the question is is a
deeper thing that you're getting out
which is so let's think about grief for
example there was this thing that
happened in the 1970s that I think is
really revealing so in the 1970s the APA
the American Psychiatric Association who
had the obviously the main body of
psychiatrists in the u.s. and
psychologists decided to do
basic kind of obvious thing they've
suddenly we've got a standardized how
depression was diagnosed across the u.s.
so up to then doctors were just
basically deciding for themselves Oh
what what depression meant so the APA
drew up a chat is simple checklist of 10
symptoms obvious things crying a lot you
know you could guess them so it's 10
simple there's 10 list of 10 symptoms
and they send it to doctors all over the
United States and they say if your
patient shows more than 5 of these 10
symptoms for more than two weeks and
diagnose them as mentally ill and do
what you can so they send this out but
within a quite a short period afterwards
psychiatrist start to come back and go
I've got a bit of a problem here if we
use this checklist in the way you're
telling us to we're going to have to
diagnose every grieving person in the
United States as depressed because these
are also the symptoms of grief and the
APA got together and they said that's
not all we men clear we didn't intend
that so they invented something that
became known as the grief loophole where
they said okay if your patients come to
you and they've got more than five of
these ten symptoms for more than two
weeks diagnose them as mentally ill
unless someone they love has died in the
last year in which case it doesn't count
then on the exception of a crazy what
exactly they started doing this but this
began to beg the question hang on a
minute why is someone you love dying
what we're saying is what we're meant to
tell dot some and Toby Blizz so if you
feel this way it's just a problem in
your brain that just needs to be drugged
into submission except there is one
circumstance in life where it's an
understandable response well why is that
the only circumstance why if my mother
dies I'm allowed to feel like that but
not if I lose my job why not if I become
homeless why not if I'm stuck in a job I
hate for the next 40 years right what
that does is a wonderful woman called
dr. Joanne cassia Tory is the leading
expert on traumatic grief in the United
States has redone amazing work on this
asking well once you acknowledge that
depression can be largely a response to
life that just challenges the whole
system we've built the system we've
built is not designed to talk about
context it's not designed to talk about
how do we sit with you and hold you and
love you and help you change your life
right as she puts it
we just don't understand pain in this
culture we've developed a bizarre way of
talking about pain it's so bizarre that
I didn't interview recently on a radio
show and well I was talking about we
were talking before in a similar way to
the way between before about loneliness
causing depression and the interview
said to me well this is an extremely
controversial theory and I thought how
did we get to the point where it was
regarded as controversial to point out
the most banal and obvious thing which
is if you're lonely you're going to be
much more likely to be acutely unhappy
and butBut so I think the grief
exception debate reveals something
really deep about how we have
misunderstood payment so Jerrod dr.
cassia Toure
it'd be great person for you to talk to
and give an intro to she's an
extraordinary woman and her baby died
during birth her daughter Cheyenne and
she was devastated and she was horrified
to be to see how many other grieving
parents were very rapidly being
diagnosed as mentally ill and and
drug-drug because the APA was so
uncomfortable with this debate about the
grief loophole they just got rid of it
doesn't exist anymore right so now you
can be diagnosed almost immediately
after your child dies in fact nine
percent of parents who lose a baby in
the United States are diagnosed and
drugged in the first 48 hours right and
it's not to cassia Tory per se we grieve
because we've loved right grief is a
testament to our love it's not a glitch
it's not a pathology it's a profound
form of love if someone you love dies it
is natural and necessary to grieve if
you interrupt that process if you
pathologize the pain if you say you know
it's a sign of good for so for example
one of Joanne's clients you know treats
people with Trump who've gone through
terrible traumatic grief you know one of
her parent one of the parents should
work with mentioned to a psychiatrist
that she when she would lie there at
night she would sometimes hear her son's
voice talking to her not in a
distressing way in fact soothed her
entirely natural form of grieving she
was diagnosed as psychotic and
prescribed loads of antipsychotics you
can see what ironic Lee what a crazy
system that is that's telling us with
crazy for having perfectly natural human
responses yeah it's interesting that
somebody would say that that these ideas
are controversial I mean there there is
a little controversy around your book
and I read a couple of those articles
trying to understand what exactly that
controversy is and it seems to me to be
a miss reading of what you actually say
in the book it's it's this perspective
that you're saying everything we know
about SSRIs and and and these these
drugs that were overprescribing to
people is wrong we shouldn't be doing
this at all and here's the real reason
when in fact you're saying listen let's
look at these SSRIs let's look at these
drugs let's look at the system and the
history behind how we got to this point
so that we can fully understand the
context of the world that we're talking
about and nowhere in the book do you say
these things should be gotten rid of you
say look if this is working for you you
should do it I've been on and off them
and for certain people they do work and
you're also not saying that any of these
ideas are new or your own or that they
aren't already part of the literature
and the protocols that a lot of you know
well-intentioned psychologists and
psychiatrists are putting into practice
with their patients it's just that it's
not enough right it's it's you're
zeroing in on the scenario in which the
overplayed scenario in which the person
goes to their shrink or doctor and
because of the health care system that
we have they have 15 minutes to type
knows this person and prescribe them
something and more often than not people
leave those appointments with with a
script that they go and they fill and
that's the end of the story there isn't
that aftercare there isn't the
functional medicine you know sort of
rubric established that gives the
well-intentioned medical practitioner
the time and the bandwidth to really
have the kind of conversations that are
required in order to provide the person
with the optimal care that they need
so there's loads of things in what you
said I think you're right that I mean so
the the people who responded to the book
in the way that the II mention I mean
they to be fettered than they admit they
hadn't read it so there was a bunch of
people who they were like they got
little snippets of it never writing
reviews but yeah so it's not even a miss
reading it's a non reading but but no I
think in terms of I do understand why
some people when they hear some of these
things find it deeply challenging
because I found it really challenging
right for thirteen years I was very
committed to the idea that my depression
was just a problem with my brain
chemistry and I found that relieving and
also always I'm happy to talk about but
I think there's a few things what you
said that are worth bringing up so one
is you're absolutely right I'm not
against chemical entity presence I just
think we need to have a nuanced
conversation about them so the two most
important facts about chemical inés
depressants that i learned from the
leading scientists in the world who'd
studied this are one is so depression is
generally measured by something called
the hamilton scale a voice felt really
sorry forever hamilton was that we had
to remember him by how miserable we are
by the way and this is the wonder 51
then yeah it goes from one where you
would be dancing around in ecstasy or
maybe on ecstasy to 51 where you would
be acutely suicidal and to give you a
sense of movement on the Hamilton scale
if you improve your sleep patterns
you'll generally gain six points on the
Hamilton scale and if you your sleep
patterns deteriorate you'll generally go
six points the other way I can
definitely validate that but and so
according to the leading expert Harvard
Medical School who's looked at the data
all the data including the data the drug
companies didn't publish but he managed
to get a hold of on average over time
chemical antidepressants will move
people 1.8 points on the Hamilton scale
its importance a few things firstly
that's an average so I initially got
much more than that over time I got less
is what I say 1.8 points is nothing
right but that's a real effect a good
night of sleep gets you 6 points yeah I
mean some people will get more than that
but I think that it's also with the and
by the way some people say he slightly
underestimates the effect on looking at
the same data they say it's three points
on the Hamilton scale but NOAA says it's
more than three points
more than half of improving asleep hands
but that fits with I think the even more
important piece of research which is
that the only good long-term research we
have on the effects of chemical
antidepressants when it comes to
depression
it's then called the star D trial it's
really simple they followed people go to
the doctor they say I'm depressed and
they follow the the study follows them
over two years to see 18 months to two
years to see well do they stop being
depressed what I found is the vast
majority of people taking chemical
antidepressant do become depressed again
now that doesn't mean they don't get
some relief they do get somebody for a
lot of them but what we can see is it's
not solving the problem and in a way I
think this is a rather banal insight it
actually in certain cases can prevent
you from solving the actual problem
because you think that you've solved it
when actually you're just treating a
symptom without actually getting at the
rationale that reason behind what's
driving the depressive emotion I think
that's I think there's several things
going on there I think you're right to
raise that so one is some people benefit
and get a benefit which outweighs the
side effects is true some of my closest
relatives
some people get a benefit and enormous
side effects like a lot of people I
gained a huge amount of weight seventy
percent of men effects their sexual
functioning all sorts of problems so
some people getting a benefit but the
side effects that way the benefit some
people don't get a benefit and get her
into side effects but I think you've
gone to them I think in a way the more
important thing which is if you are told
a story that your depression is simply a
biological problem and can only be
treated with drugs it comes back to what
we were saying that just tells people
there's no meaning to their pain it
actually cuts them off from finding the
causes of their pain in their life and
it cuts us off as a society but I would
just say just a second thought about
what you said before and it's worth
saying this is not my views is to view
the leading medical body in the world
World Health Organization but when you
said you know so part of the problem is
that your doctors only have 15 minutes
and so when it's actually seven minutes
now is the average but B that's true
there's an even deeper thing if we think
about road accidents right car accidents
there's still the single biggest cause
of death although opioids are coming up
close behind it in our society and
worrying about how do we prevent road
accidents
one of the deaths and car crashes one of
the things we do is we have doctors in
emergency rooms and they do heroic jobs
when someone's already been horrific ly
mauled and the doctors are heroes and
they're amazing but they are not the
people who save the most lives right
what do we do as a society we have
driving tests so we make sure you can
drive before you get onto the road we
have speed limits with seat belts we
have air bags we send the cops out to
chase down people driving chaotically to
see if their duis or drug driving
environmental control exactly precisely
because it's a social problem we have an
enormous social response of which one
part which is amazing in heroic is the
biomedical response of doctors patching
you back together but that's one thing
on a big long list right um in the same
way the evidence is overwhelming that
depression and anxiety have huge social
and psychological causes alongside the
biological causes right very few people
will dispute that although it's rare
lead explained to the public and that
needs a social response right so there
are lots of things that the evidence
shows very clearly can reduce this
epidemic that are much earlier down the
chain if you like man by the time the
person becomes acutely depressed and
goes to the doctor so I give you an
example I noticed that lots of the
people I know they were depressed and
anxious the depression anxiety focuses
around their work so I started to to
think about the people I know unusual I
such look at the evidence of this so
Gallup did the best research enormous
study three years study that figured out
how people feel about their jobs in the
United States what they found was 13% of
us liked our jobs most of the time 1 3 %
63% that's higher about 63% of what they
called sleep working you don't like it
you don't hate it you just kind of get
through the day at 24 percent of people
hate and fear their jobs there's quite a
connoisseur that that means 87 percent
of people don't like the thing they're
doing most of their waking lives and
jobs
you know most jobs these days are not
9:00 to 5:00
there you know from the minute you wake
up in the morning and check your phone
to the last you know check on the phone
before you go to bed and constantly
we're you know we're all on call 24/7 if
you don't like what you do I can't it's
it's academic that this is gonna lead to
psychological issues well I think that's
Ryan I started to look for the evidence
for how to is there any evidence about
depression and work I discovered this is
amazing man Australian social scientist
I went to go and seek what professor
Michael Marmot who made a real
breakthrough about this in the 1970s so
he discovered the key factor not the
only one but the key factor that causes
depression at work if you go to work
tomorrow and you are controlled so you
have low or no control over your work
you are much more likely to become
depressed and anxious and at first when
I was looking at this evidence and I
went to interview first a moment a few
times I kept misunderstanding it I
thought the lesson that this was okay
you've got this elite 13% at the top who
get to have nice jobs where they control
it and they're going to be fine and then
you've got everyone else who's condemned
to this shitty life and I thought wow my
brother's an uber driver my dad was a
bus driver my grandmother's job was to
clean toilets are we saying that like
these people are lover condemned and
professor Marmot kept explaining it's
not the work that makes you depressed
it's a lack of control over the work and
there's something we can do about that
which I think is the equivalent of your
seat bags and your DUI arrests right so
I went to Baltimore and went to
interview a wonderful person called
Meredith Keough and Meredith used to go
to bed every Sunday night just sick with
anxiety and she had an office job as she
would tell you it wasn't the worst
office job in the world she wasn't being
bullied or harassed or anything but it
was monotonous low control she can bear
the thought this was going to be the
next 40 years of her life so one day
with her husband Josh Meredith did this
quite bold thing and at first some
people hear this the thing I'm gonna
think I'm saying you should do this -
are you gonna think I can't do that and
it's true most people can't it leads to
a different insight so Josh works in a
bike store in Baltimore and you know and
he'd done it since he was a teenager and
as you can imagine that's insecure work
it's controlled what you don't even have
any vacation paid vacation or
paid sick pay unless your boss happens
to be generous one day Josh and his
colleagues were in their bike store and
they just asked themselves what does
that boss actually do right they're like
their boss he wasn't a terrible guy but
they were like we seem to fix all the
bikes and he seems to make all the money
could this could this work out
differently here and they decided they
were going to set up a bike store at
that owned that works on a different
principle
it's the place they'd worked before was
a corporation right most people
listening to your show working
corporations you know how it works
you've got a boss at the top he's like
The Dictator and we're all the little
serfs and sometimes the dictator chooses
to be nice and sometimes they don't but
you don't have much say over that Josh
and his friends and colleagues and
Meredith decided they were gonna set up
a bike store that works on a different
principle an older American principal
it's a democratic cooperative that I
have a boss they take the decisions
about the business together by voting in
practice they agree almost all the time
but they vote once of a couple of weeks
and they share the profits obviously
they share out the good tasks and the
shitty tasks so now I get stuck with the
shitty tasks and one of things that was
fascinating spending time with them at
Baltimore bicycle works which is their
store
is how many of them talked about having
been depressed and anxious in this
previous way of working but were not
depressed and anxious in this different
way of working and it and it totally
fits with what Professor Marmot had
taught me it's not like they quit their
jobs fixing bikes and went off to become
Beyonce's backing singers right they fix
bikes before they fix bikes now the
difference is now they've got control
over their work and when you control
your work you can create meaning out of
it right if you have an idea you can try
to persuade the people around you you
can try to put it into practice
you don't feel humiliated you don't feel
subordinated there's no reason why we
should be structuring our society so
most of us are spending time in
institutions that make us feel like [ __ ]
right we can see sense of agency exactly
right it's I mean it's multifaceted
because you have ownership you have
decision-making control you have some
you know sense of decision-making power
over your hours I would imagine there's
a whole variety of things that get
played into that but fundamentally it's
about agency over your life most people
lack that whether it's in their job or
other
areas of their life that's gonna lead to
a sense of disempowerment that I think
will quickly you know cascade into
despair you have a that's a breakaway
pair you have a natural human need to to
seek meaning in your life and if you're
doing something that's controlled by
someone else almost all of your waking
hours that disrupts your ability to
create meaning out of it right I think
the idea of meaning gets confused like
the if you say well does your life have
meaning or what is the you know are you
living a meaningful life that can get
misconstrued into you know this idea
that you're on a grand quest answer some
Universal question or something like
that but I think yeah you're searching
for the ring or you're trying to find
God but it's really just I think some
some sense of control and purposefulness
on a very basic level that so many of us
so many of us lack and as you know
cities become larger and all these what
you're seeing is the the the
acceleration of specialization and all
of these fields we're now jobs become so
regimented into performing these very
you know very specific tasks you see it
in medicine and used to be the family
doctor who paid house calls now every
doctor has a very specific specialty
that allows them to be very good at that
one thing but they they lack a general
understanding or not like we lose sight
of the bigger picture and I think when
you know we're being funneled in that
direction of greater and greater
specificity with that comes a loss of
that level of the agency as well this is
one of the causes of them depression and
anxiety that I brought about a lost
connections that I found quite
challenging actually so everyone knows
that junk food has taken over our diets
and made us physically sick but there's
equally strong evidence that a kind of
junk values have taken over our minds
and made us mentally sick enough
question about it yeah but for thousands
of years philosophers have said you know
for
fuchsias to Socrates on down if you
think life is about money and status and
showing off you can feel like [ __ ] right
that's not an exact quote from Confucius
but that is the gist of what he said we
all think worthy gonna be the exemption
to that rule though yeah like yeah yeah
yeah I get it but well this is what's
first thing because although people have
thought that for a long time no one had
actually scientifically investigated it
until I got until an incredible man I
got to know called Professor Tim caso
who's at Knox College in Illinois
started to do amazing research into this
professor Cass had discovered some
really important things one of things he
discovered is the more you think life is
about money and status and showing off
the more likely you are to become
depressed and anxious because that's not
a way of living that meets your deeper
needs he also found as a society as a
culture we've become much more driven by
these drunk values that really begun to
dominate the culture at the time and and
it's making us feel paranoid there's a
little experiment it's wasn't number
professor caso it was done just before
he started his work but I think it's
kind of a revealing one stone in 1978
it's very simple they've got a bunch of
five-year-olds and they split them into
two groups and the first group was shown
in advertisement two advertisements for
a specific toy whatever the equivalent
of Dora the Explorer or the Teletubbies
was in 1970 a second group was shown no
advertisements then they say to all the
kids okay kids you got a choice now you
can either play with a nice boy it
doesn't have the toy that was in the ad
or you can play with a nasty boy who's
got the toy that was in the ad the kids
who have not seen the advert she's the
nice boy the kids who haven't so the
kids who haven't seen out virtues the
nice boy the kids you have seen the
advertisement choose the nasty boy he's
got the toy just two advertisements
primed those kids to choose an inanimate
lump of plastic over the possibility of
connection and fun and friendship right
everyone sees more than two adverts a
day right we're just bombarded where
they aren't like goodness I mean I don't
know what the number is but it's got to
be in the hundreds if not thousands
every single day depending upon where
you live in your media habits
well it's professor caso put it to me
you know we will we all live in a
machine that is designed to get us to
neglect what is important in life right
nobody listening to your show thinks
they're gonna lie on their deathbed and
think about all the things they bought
right they will lie on their deathbed
and think about moments of love and
connection and meaning in their lives
and yet we've created a culture that is
designed to get us to neglect those
things and Professor Castle proposes two
kinds of solutions to this so one is we
need to just get these contaminants out
of the environment right analogous to
getting rid of environmental
contaminants you know so I went to asar
Paulo in Brazil but they just banned
outdoor advertising right that's one
thing we can do we should much more
tightly regulate advertising advertising
is the ultimate frenemy right imagine an
advert that said to you hey rich you
look great today you smell great you're
doing fine you don't need anything more
save your money that would be the worst
advert ever right from the perspective
of the advertising industry advertise in
the appetizer industry talks about this
openly in their documents it's about
creating manufactured once manufactured
needs creating a feelings of inadequacy
that they then have to keep selling the
solution to over and over again there
was a kind of example a few years ago
that was a nice illustrative rare moment
when people push back we're and I think
it was dove although I could be wrong a
cosmetics company it started to sell a
product they said are you embarrassed by
how wrinkly and disgusting your armpits
are compassionately we've created this
beautiful solution of course no one was
worried about how their armpits look
because no sane person things about that
right
of course what it's subtle is saying is
you like the ultimate frenemy oh babe I
really care about you I'm on your side
just so you know people are kind of
saying your armpits look gross you can
see how it works right
that was a moment when people really
kicked back there was another good
moment in London and I guess two years
ago now we're a company that did I think
there were protein shakes launched a
huge ad campaign all over the London
subway system that said are you beach
body ready and her picture of an
impossibly buff man or woman right the
implication being if you don't look like
these people you're not ready and you
better start drinking our protein shakes
right
and there was a huge backlash to get
people vandalized and in the end they
took them down from the subway system I
think the mayor actually Maryland and
city can actually banned them because of
course we could see the occasionally
they go too far and we see the implicit
message right but most of the time we're
just soaking this up so part of the
solution is get the contaminants out of
the environment just get rid of most
advertising extremely tightly regulate
what remains but how likely is that a
lot more likely than gay marriage scene
fifty years ago you think wow you know a
lot more likely than a black president
seen fifty years ago a lot more likely
than President Trump seemed five years
ago right is a go either way but the
we're all the beneficiaries of things
that seem completely impossible right I
mean my grandmother's will not allow to
have a bank account once they got
married right of their own and that's
not so long ago right the weekend was a
crazy radical idea when American trade
unionists proposed it for the first time
now we take it for granted you know so
and we're all the beneficiaries of
impossible seeming things that people
fought for and didn't give up and
demanded but the professor also said
there's another and other set of
solutions which are actually more
immediately achievable which are about
how we inculcate these these more
meaningful values in ourselves so he did
this interesting experiment with a guy
called Nathan donger and who I
interviewed so Nathan was a camp at a
kind of slightly funny way Nathan was a
financial advisor in Minneapolis to
adults help him do budgeting things like
that and one day he got contacted by the
school in a middle-class day but not
really a neighborhood saying that we've
got a problem the kids in their school
we're demanding really expensive
consumer objects like Nike sneakers and
they were getting extremely distressed
when they didn't get them and it was
freaking out school is freaking out the
parents are like what can we do cut in
they asked him to come in and do what he
did which was give budgeting advice so
he comes in to advise the kids on
budgeting and quite quickly realizes
this ain't a budgeting issue right
there's something deeper going on here
so he starts to work with the heat of
this interesting experiment there's
their monitored set up with Professor
Casa that was monitor
so what they did is they would get
teenagers and their parents to come they
would meet in groups I think it was once
a fortnight for six months something
like that and at first the first thing
the very first session the teenagers and
parents had to write down what they
thought they had to have write an
initial course people would initially
say food and shelter and perfectly
sensible things and quite quickly the
teenagers would say I got to have you
know whatever the latest designer object
was and and then they would say tell me
what you would feel if you got those
objects if you got that thing quite
quickly the teammate quite quickly it
was clearly not about an inherent
property of the consumer object so for
example when I was a teenager I remember
craving Nike sneakers you could not have
had a child who was further away from
playing basketball like Michael Jordan
than me right why did I want it you know
why did these kids want it they would
say things like what I would feel
accepted by the group yeah its social
acceptance it's where you fall in the
social pecking order and I think at that
age the social dynamics are feel like
life and death
it's very acute at that age and it
didn't take long for the kids to
articulate what you're saying for them
to go WOW why do I think that right they
didn't need much prompting as the
sessions went on - where did you get the
idea that you will have value as an
individual if you have this lump of
shitty right from that 8,000 commercials
and billboards that I've seen in the
last 24 hours
exactly said they would firstly what
they did was work on seeing well where
did those junk values come from they
look at the ads everyone likes to think
they're smarter than the ad and everyone
began to realize how [ __ ] the ad got me
right but then they did it what I
thought was the more interesting bit
they began to say okay we'll set that
stuff aside what do you actually value
what do you think is actually important
in life and they started writing about
they start discussing in groups we don't
really have those conversations very
often in our culture certainly much less
than we have conversations about
shopping and they start talking about
what they actually thought was important
what actually gave them joy and their
life something talked about playing
music something talked about just love
the whole range of things I'm typing in
the natural world
and they talk about what how could you
build more of that stuff into your life
and less of the junk and they started to
do and this was monitored over time and
what it's been was just this
intervention and meeting once a
fortnight
led to a really significant shift in
people's values well this tells us
professor casiraghi is I think
persuasively it's these insights to just
below the surface right and this is not
like explaining quantum physics or
complex linguistics or something in some
ways these are almost banal insights and
yet the reason they have to be stated
and argued for it's because we created a
culture that's all about getting us to
not see them it's a machine that in fact
faces real challenges if we stop buying
crap right the problem is if we carry on
buying the crap and thinking that's what
life is about we have the crisis not
that system so I think it's about and
you can see again I really touched on a
few of the causes obviously that I
talked about lost connections but you
can see again this is a very different
story than telling someone there's just
a chemical missing in your brain and all
you need to do is drug yourself right it
leads to a different set of attempted
solutions and I believe very strongly in
antidepressants in the sense that people
are really depressed they're not making
it up they're not imagining it they are
terribly depressed and anxious they need
solutions to that but what I argue is we
need to expand our concept - what
antidepressants are for some people one
of the things on the menu should remain
chemical antidepressants they have value
but we need a much broader range of
enter presence on the CAO model right
that group that Nathan and professor
castle ed where they got people to talk
about their values and it shifted their
values over time that's an
antidepressant that gardening program in
East London that was an antidepressant
up to the last third of the book is
about these different kinds of
antidepressants they are just as real
and just as important easily as the the
kind of chemical solutions because
they're tending to some of the other
causes yeah yeah yeah and and I think
we're seeing some interesting cultural
movements at the moment that are kind of
incarnations of what you're talking
about I mean this whole minimalism thing
that a lot of young people are super you
know all about and keen on
that didn't really exist even I don't
know five or ten years ago now there's
movies about it there's movements
there's YouTube channels there's people
with podcasts about this who are
basically speaking to Gen Z and saying
listen everything that you see all
around you every single day is promising
you a lie the answers that you seek will
not be found you know in these in this
material way and in truth that which we
seek the most will be found through
connectivity through getting back to
nature to these things that you're
talking about and it requires like a
material shedding as much as it does
kind of a psychological rebooting of
your software to really understand that
you need to look at the world through a
different pair of glasses I think that's
true and I think it's interesting this
is playing out with teenagers so much
because the figures for teenage distress
are really shocking yeah I mean what are
they they're super high that exception
however this is varying the problem is
it's difficult to measure distress over
time because some of the figures that
show astronomical increases I think are
slightly misleading because there's been
a decline in stigma of talking about it
so that would mean that more people for
example my grandmother I'm sure from
having discussed this with her while she
was alive and it was terribly depressed
in her 30s and 40s if anyone had ever
asked her are you depressed you would I
said no and she won't never was dream to
go into the doctor so there's been
whereas it would you know if you know a
relative mind the same age now does that
they would they would say yes and they
would get help they would go to the
doctor for help so I think the kind of
stratospheric figures for increase are
misleading but I do think there's good
evidence there has been a significant
increase
we know the teenage suicide for example
has gone up which is also very
relatively easy way of measuring extreme
distress but I want to think about
obviously one of the factors we think
about when we talk about teenagers is
social media and so on I want to think
about this one places that really helped
me to understand is I went to the first
of an Internet rehab center in the
United States oh wow
there's something like that yes it's
allowed it does it should exist it's in
Spokane it's just outside Spokane in
Washington and I remember when I arrived
there remember getting out the car and
absolutely instinctively looking at my
phone and being really pissed off there
was no reception check my email I was
like no Wi-Fi it was hell what can I say
but I remember going in there and
talking to these the so they get what so
kind this place called restart
Washington they get all kinds of people
at restart Washington but they
disproportionately get young men who
become obsessed with these multiplayer
world play games like World of Warcraft
or fortnight or their fort I didn't
exist at the time that I was there it's
become an issue for them since I'm sure
and especially these young men I was
Gladys Pollock I was getting this kind
of insight and then I spoke to dr.
Hillary cash who runs the co runs the
place it was a great person as she
really helped me to understand it so she
said to me something like you've got to
ask yourself what are these young men
getting out of these games they're
getting the things they used to get from
the culture but they no longer get so
what do they get they get a sense of
tribe and identity they get a sense of
status and a way they can gain status
that they can feel they're good at
something and they get a sense they're
physically roaming around the average
child in Britain now spends less time
outdoors than the average maximum
security prisoner because by law our
Maximus creepers in the house times
seventy minutes a day and most of our
kids don't get that but what they're
getting is like a kind of parody of
those things right I began to think as I
was speaking to her in the young men
there the relationship between social
media and social life is a bit like the
relationship between porn and sex right
I'm not anti porn but if your entire sex
life consists of looking at porn you're
going to be going around pissed off and
irritated the whole time because you
didn't evolve to masturbate over a
screen you evolved to have sex in the
same way and there's a place for
screen-based of direction of course I'm
not some weird Luddite
but that's not what we evolved to have
if you and I were having this
conversation over Skype
I wouldn't feel you were hearing me and
you wouldn't feel you were hearing no
other way around in the way that we feel
we're hearing and seeing each other now
right and and that let me to think about
what you've got to think about when did
the internet arrive right because it's
you can get to a simplistic dialogue
where you say this is just the
Internet's for the Internet's this
horrorshow actually think about it and
you look at the evidence on this the
Internet arrives for most of us in the
late 90s the early 2000s I set my first
email in the year 2000 and a lot not all
but a lot of the causes of depression
and anxiety that I write about in lost
connections had actually already been
supercharged by that point so we've
talked about coupling the loneliness
meaningless work and but junk values and
what happens is the internet arrives and
it looks a lot like the things we've
lost right you've lost friends here's
the whole range of Facebook friends
you've lost status do as many status
updates as you want right but again it's
it's it's like a parody of the thing
we've lost and the expert on loneliness
professor John Cacioppo said to me I'm a
good kind of rule of thumb which is if
you're turning to the Internet as a way
station to meet people offline great if
it's the last destination on the line
generally something's gone wrong yeah
it's it's it's a tricky thing because
this is the the lexicon you know this is
how more and more people are
communicating and the solution isn't to
completely put the phone away and never
use it and become a Luddite but these
devices are specifically designed to
create that addictive response I mean I
think this is a perfect example of where
the work that you've done in addiction
and depression dovetail directly into
each other because you have a highly
addictive device in the hands of an
undeveloped young mind with apps on it
that are specifically created to create
that you know
seratonin response that makes it almost
impossible for that kid to put that
phone away so short of completely
putting it away how do we as a parent
like this is something I think about all
the time like how do we create
structures around it to foster a healthy
relationship with the best of what it
can do which is you know like they
communicate with their friends and they
see their friends at school so there is
that offline component to it but it very
easily if left unchecked can devolve and
I think it doesn't has with thousands if
not millions of teenagers into a
compulsive behavior pattern that is
truly an addiction that you know leads
these young people to a very very dark
place and it's not necessarily just
young people I think that's true and I
think we've always got to look at a bit
like going back to rat Park that
addiction occurs in a context right I
think it's worth explaining people the
way we are raising our children is
deeply weird and has never been tried by
any group we have beens but we have no
idea the long term mean just with our
phones if you think about the nuclear
family right where the child remains
indoors with two adults or if they're
lucky or one I don't they're not that's
not a model of child rearing that's ever
been tried by human beings right human
beings have always been raised by
villages by groups by tribes right it's
a very recent thing that we would
imprison our children in the home and
get them try to get them to get all
their emotional or most of their
emotional needs from just one or two
adults who by the way of working 50
hours a week or whatever it is so we've
got this I think the the cell phone
addiction occurs rather like the heroin
addiction in the rats occurred in the
circumstances of isolation and
imprisonment the cell phone addiction is
an unmet psychological needs the self
suffers an addiction is happening in a
context where the children's basic needs
are not being met this wonderful guy
called professor Peter gray or speaking
to about this recently in Boston so just
children have a need to run around they
have a need to play
and unsupervised play there's a lot of
evidence unsupervised play is an
absolutely essential part of child
development there's been I think the
figure is something like a 20 percent
decline at least in unsupervised play in
the last 10 years right
just a seraph Raider let their kids go
outside and Hall yeah or when they do
play they've got to be constantly
referencing back to you know the adult
furred
what do I do now what do I do now or
it's all super organized exactly from
structured event to a structured event
exactly that's and that's good for
children in some of course and as part
of a balanced diet that's a healthy
thing but if that's most of what the kid
is getting they're not able to develop
in a healthy way and so you've got this
context of a very weird form of toxic
childhood and weird child ring often
tragically motivated by laughs right not
motivated by desire to hurt the child
quite the opposite a desire to protect
the child that has led to it so in that
context tips if the one thing that gives
you any sense of relief or pleasure is
the phone for tonight whatever it is
you're gonna tell it's not to dispute
there are things about the game these
games are designed by some of the
cleverest people in the world to keep
you hooked at the point you're making it
absolutely right but like all addiction
you need to look at the object to the
addiction and then the context in which
the addiction occurs and I think both
those things are really important and
the factors that are causing depression
or anxiety in adults through unmet needs
I even more heartbreaking when you see
them playing out in children and we're
doing the same over biology zation I
think one of the great scandals in this
country is 30% of children in the foster
care system I've been given at least one
psychiatric drug I mean think about that
it is not the 30% of children in the
foster care system happened to have
defective brains right these are
profoundly distressed children and as a
culture what are we doing rather than
dealing with their distress loving them
caring for them looking after them
we're drugging them into submission
that's 30% by the way at any given time
so it's actually more over
over the span of their time in foster
care that's an obscenity one in ten
American thirteen year old American boys
has been given a stimulant drug at any
time you don't tell me that one in ten
American boys has some kind of defective
broken diseased brain this is [ __ ]
right these are kids who who need to you
know need love they need to have their
needs met any to run around they need to
play there's all sorts of things going
on here that are being boiled down in
this extraordinarily simplistic way to
you know a brain disease that needs to
be drugged not to say that some of them
don't have some problems in their brains
of course they do but this is a we've
ended up with a grossly simplistic
narrative about our distress from
childhood where they're drugged into
submission too when you're in an old
people's home in half to the McCue of
antipsychotics to shut them up you know
right the way through their lives this
is not a sensible way we need to think
in a much deeper more honest more loving
and complex way about our distress I
mean to listen to the signals that it's
giving us what are the statistics on the
diagnosis of ADHD with kids you know
super high right and I often wonder like
are we over diagnosing these people
certainly we're over medicating them and
we've thought we've created this
syndrome or disease and look I'm not a
doctor I'm not gonna say it doesn't
exist but there is an argument that you
know a hyperactive kid or a slightly
active kid who has trouble sitting in a
classroom and focusing there's an
argument to be made that that's
perfectly normal on a child of that age
and to pathologize that and say we need
to medicate this kid because he can't
pay attention I think is really
problematic well you get rid of recess
and gym and kids can't sit still and
you've got something these children are
developed brain diseases how what a
funny coincidence right it's not to say
there aren't some children who for
complex range of reasons genuinely had
problems focusing and need has certainly
there are yeah but this connects to
another thing that it was the hardest
cause of depression and anxiety for me
to write
about and it has a manifestation in very
related to what your what you're saying
so if I tell you the story of how it was
discovered for a minute you're gonna
think why is he telling me this what's
that got to in the bath icky he's only
possible to really understand us our
story so not so far from here in San
Diego in the mid-1980s a doctor called
dr. Vincent felitti was given a quite
difficult task he was approached by
Kaiser Permanente the big not-for-profit
medical provider in San Diego and here
in California and they said to him look
we've got a big problem every year
obesity is rising and everything we're
trying like giving people diet advice
all that stuff none of it's working what
can we do and so they gave him quite a
big budget and they said look just do
blue skies research figure out what the
hell we can do so dr. Phil Eddie started
to work with 250 extremely obese people
weighed more than 400 pounds and one day
he's interviewing one of them and he has
this idea which seems like an insult I
mean actually is the kind of dumb idea
he asked himself what would happen it
really obese people literally just
stopped eating and we gave them like a
vitamin C shot so they didn't get scurvy
and all of those things would they just
burn through the fat stores in their
body and get down to a normal way so
obviously with a huge amount of medical
supervision they start doing this and in
one sense it worked so there's a woman
who I'm going to call Susan to protect
her medical confidentiality who went
down from being more than a more than
400 pounds to 138 pounds credible right
her family are telling dr. Phil Edie he
saved her life
she's rejoicing he's rejoicing and then
one day something happened they didn't
expect Susan cracked
she starts obsessively eating at KFC or
wherever it was and quite soon she's
back at a dangerous way and she comes in
to see dr. palete he calls her in and he
says and what happened and she looks
down she's really ashamed as I don't
know I don't know not sure Wally said
well tell me about the day he cracked
what happened that day it turns out
something had happened that day that had
never happened to Susan
she'd been in a bar and a man had hit on
her nothing like a predatory or awful
way but
sexual interest in her she felt really
frightened she when I start eating it's
not explicit II thought it was
interesting he said to her when did you
start to put on weight in her case it
was when she was 11 he said did anything
happen when you were 11 that didn't
happen when you were 5 or 9 or 14 I
think that year and she looked down and
she said yeah that's what my grandfather
started to rape me he started to
interview everyone in the program he
discovered that 55% of them had put on
their extreme weight in the aftermath of
being sexually abused he was really
puzzled by this like what's going on
here Susan explained it to him she said
overweight is overlooked and that's what
I wanted to be he realized this thing
that seems pathological and of course is
bad for you obesity was performing a
function right I had a rational function
I was protecting them such a defense
mechanism for dealing with unhealed
childhood trauma you know it makes
perfect sense it's vit it's very much in
the vein of what Gabor monta talks about
unhealed childhood trauma fueling
addiction or unhealthy behavior patterns
it's so interesting that all it took was
this person asking the right questions
to get to the bottom of what was fueling
this entire problem for a woman it's
interesting because this was a
relatively small study so doctor felitti
it's hard to draw conclusions from that
you know a group of 250 people so dr.
filleted he went to the CDC the Center
for Disease Control the main body that
funds medical research in the United
States and he got a huge amount of
funding to do this to do a massive study
so everyone who came to San Diego
everyone everyone in San Diego who came
for medical care for an entire year and
was given no matter what for headaches
broken legs schizophrenia anything was
given a questionnaire had two parts
first part said did any of these bad
things happen to you when you were a kid
things like sexual abuse physical abuse
neglect the second part asked have you
had any of these problems as an adult
things like obesity addiction suicide
attempts depression and at first when
they calculated it out
the CDC thought they'd made a mistake
because the figures were so extreme for
every category of childhood trauma you
experienced you were 2 to 4 times more
likely to become depressed and anxious
but it was when you got into the
multiple categories that figures just
exploded if you'd had six categories of
childhood trauma you were three thousand
100 percent more like to attempted
suicide and 4600 percent to have an
addiction problem is we just don't get
figures like that very often and it's
funny when I remember but the first day
first time I interviewed dr. Billy T I
went to see him in down in San Diego and
he's a wonderful wonderful man and if
you met him you would really admire him
and I remember leaving and like shaking
with anger being so angry actually
thought I might hit him which is really
awesome what why am i reacting this way
this is so weird
and I had experienced as a child some
very extreme acts from an adult in my
life and I remember thinking that day
you know I'd never thought about that in
relation to my depression which seems
ludicrous now looking back at it was
that a repressed memory or just always
remembered I just miss it over yeah I
mean I was dismissive of it it's just it
was in one silo in my head you know
under stuff that happened then and I
don't really think of it as related to
the silo that was about depression and
anxiety and why I might feel that way I
think it's one of the reasons actually
why I clung to this very simplistic
story my doctor told me about serotonin
for so long because then you don't
really have to go look at that yeah I
didn't want it exactly I didn't want to
think about I don't want to give this
individual power over me now I didn't
want to think about these things but one
of the reasons I'm glad that I did stay
with this insight and I did go and see
dr. blue T again was because of what he
discovered next right so once I've done
this study and people all over San Diego
a lot of them had indicated that
experienced childhood trauma the doctor
was told net don't call them back but
next time they come in say to them
something like this I see that when you
were child you were sexually abused or
whatever the nature of the beast was I'm
really sorry that happened to you that
should never have happened
would you like to talk about it 40% of
people said I don't want to talk about
it as 60% of people did want to talk
about it and they want to talk about it
on average for five minutes what was
extraordinary was just those five
minutes of an authority figures saying
I'm so sorry that should never have
happened
that alone led to a significant fall in
depression and anxiety and then it was
randomly as some of them were randomly
assigned to a therapist to talk about it
more and they had an even bigger fool
and the reason is I think it fits with a
much wider body of research into shame
the guy called professor James
Pennebaker at Florida State University
has done interesting work on this so we
know that shame destroys you right
physically mentally destroys you during
the AIDS crisis openly gay men died on
average two years later than closeted
gay men even when they got health care
at the same time right
shame is desperately physically
destructive and mentally destructive and
those things of course I'm not entirely
separate as you've done lots of work on
and giving people a way to release their
shame it's profoundly physically healing
and mentally healing it in fact should
be regarded as an antidepressant and you
know it was after but one of the other
scientists who worked on that program a
man called dr. Robert ander said to me
it made him realize when we see someone
who's behaving with an apparent
pathology whether it's obesity addiction
depression we need to stop asking what's
wrong with you and start asking what
happened to you and I think it was that
more than any other that causes a
depression anxiety that I learned about
other of the other eight are really
important that made me realize how
mistaken what my doctor did was when I
was a teenager right so I've gone to my
doctor I've been profoundly distressed
I'm not sure I suspected the doctor had
said to me has anything happened to you
that made you this way I would not have
been able to talk about it anyway so I
don't want to be simplistic about this
but the fact that I was given a story
I was given a story that diverted me
from these real causes that was the only
cause of my depression but I think it
was really significant the story I was
told diverted me from that story now
with my complicity for sure and I think
I would have been able to deal with my
depression much earlier
had I been told a more truthful of
complex and nuanced story and given a
more complex menu of options for how to
respond to it mm-hmm
that's not a criticism of that
individual doctor who had seven minutes
to see each patient is and I'm sure was
saying what he honestly thought was true
but it is a criticism of a society
that's put in this position that's
responding to distress children and
distressed adults with this remarkably
simplistic story that we know isn't
right yeah I mean there is I mean there
are plenty of people I quote would have
happened had you been directed to
therapy instead right and told listen
you're gonna get you know six one-hour
sessions and you can sit there and not
answer any other questions but you're
gonna have to show up for them like if
your parent or somebody in your family
had said look we can see your suffering
like let's try this
perhaps that would have led you in a
different direction I think part of the
problem is that most of the therapy that
people are assigned to is cognitive
behavioral therapy right which does have
some value so people might not know
cognitive behavioral therapies descends
from the ideas of a psychologist called
Aaron Beck who basically argued I'm
slightly caricaturing him but I think
most of his followers slightly coquetry
him as well that that most of our
problems certainly depression come from
defective thought patterns right there's
some truth in this this is not untrue
right we all know people for example I
saw someone but not so too many details
about this but I recently here in LA saw
an old friend whose life is going great
and his miserable as hell and just is
one of those people who just looks at
all their benefits in life we're kind of
looking for the worst and everything
right welcome to Los Angeles
[Laughter]
actually all my British friends here
with one exception I like that but the
UM that is poor cognitive skills right
partly and there's lots of other things
going on in that individuals life
obviously I don't want to be simplistic
but that person has poor cognitive
skills their thought patterns tend them
to look for the worst and I believe this
individual would benefit from CBT so I'm
not saying there's no role for CBT but I
also think CBT is really limited right
now there are lots of CBT practitioners
who go beyond the limits of CBT are
actually complex and so on but it's
limited because this explanation of
human distress is really limited and
think about that farmer in the field in
Cambodia
you know who's having to you know with a
artificial leg is having to work in the
rice fields right now the CBT treatment
for him would be to say we've got a her
mom well know wouldn't know it wouldn't
even be let's talk about your mother
that's the Freudian thing right it'd be
even worse than that that maybe it would
bring up trouble about his mother what
they would say is we've got to think
about the thought patterns that only I
mean if they were to adhere strictly to
the simplistic edicts of this I suspect
my CBT practitioners would be more
sophisticated but it would be to say
let's think about how we can alter your
thought patterns and your habits of mind
so you will be less distressed right
that guy didn't need CBT that guy needed
a cow he needed a practical intervention
to change his environment right there
are some people who but will benefit
from CBT I'm in favor of it for some
people in fact recommended it to my
friend but that's not most of what's
going on right it's not attending to
most of what's going on which is why the
evidence shows rather like with chemical
antidepressants for most people
CBT has a real effect that diminishes
quite rapidly over time right so I think
problem is we there's a reason by the
way why CBT is very popular with
neoliberal governments whether it's in
Britain massively championed by David
Cameron in Florida Governor Rick Scott
there's a whole range of places that
champion because it's basically I kind
of get back to work right come on now
come on now enough of this silly
thinking we're going to get you back to
work minutes again I'm caricaturing but
they
is an aspect of it that's like that
right rather than say Joanne cassia Tory
who's the amazing woman to do that work
on grief which is about you know you're
not wrong to feel terrible your thought
patterns in for many people you're not
wrong to be angry and distressed not a
fact you should be angry distressed in
hostile in this situation let's use that
anger and hostility to change your
environment and I think the most
important places I saw were places where
they had they sit on those insights
which is not say CBT doesn't have some
useful insights it's interesting well I
love the idea of how powerful can be to
change your environment and when I look
at you don't like we go through the
causes that you talked about in your
book that are contributing to this
epidemic of anxiety and depression and
they all kind of fall under this you
know rubric of disconnection and the
solutions are all about reconnection and
when I look when I hear you talking
about you know changing your environment
to make the environment more conducive
to the solution it reminds me of the
work that Dan Buettner has done with
Blue Zones you know this soda so Dan is
an amazing guy and he spent many years
traveling all over the world to find the
people the cultures that live the
longest the highest concentration per
capita of centenarians he found these
another six or nine of them or something
like that they're called Blue Zones
they're in places that have been sort of
removed from modern progress for lack of
a better phrase like II Korea and the
Nicoya Peninsula and Costa Rica there's
various pockets around the world and
there's one in just outside of Los
Angeles with the seventh-day Adventist
faith community and it's super
interesting what he's discovered and
then he kind of was found something yeah
super interesting I'm getting to the
more interesting relevant part for you
but then he then did it again to say
okay I want to find the happiest people
and there was some overlap between these
happiness blue zones and
centenarian Blue Zones and then he was
able to extract from this experience and
all the time that he spent with these
people to kind of define the principles
that are contributing to longevity and
happiness and and these overlap as well
and they're very similar to yours like
it's almost a blueprint here that's
emerging if you were to synthesize his
work in your work and so much of it is
about connection and you know from his
perspective connection you know it's
about maintaining households with your
elders and keeping the extended family
around it's about your faith community
it's about always moving your body
gently throughout the day it's all of
these things that we have done
historically throughout the ages of
human evolution that it's only recently
that we've been disconnected from so I
think that's super interesting and now
he has this program where he goes to
cities who have high incidences of
obesity and on you know lots of
unhealthy people and and you know
insurance companies that you know
corporations that are paying high
premiums I want to get their premiums
down and he helps consult with
governments and corporations to create
systems and structures that will
contribute to a healthier population
that will live longer and ultimately you
know through this experience he will say
to you look you can give people you can
have them read self-help books you can
give them this diet or that diet or tell
them they need to do this that or the
other thing but ultimately for the most
part like these things don't really work
or they don't stick over the long haul
what does work is when you change the
environment to make the environment
conducive to the healthy choice whether
that healthy choice is emotional mental
physical
nutrition-related whatever it is the
healthy choice has to be at arm's reach
so you have to create bike paths and
make bikes available you know make it
easy for people to ride their bikes to
work as a simple example you need to get
the soda machines out of the schools
like very simple things so that doing
that doing the unhealthy thing becomes
harder or
and when I look at your work and I think
about how that applies to depression
anxiety mental illness even addiction
and certain respects like I see a lot of
overlap yeah I think that's true there's
there's a académica interview called
breath for dr. Brett Ford who did up in
Berkeley did this original research I
think is very relevant to what you just
said
it's quite simple she did with her
colleagues they did it in four countries
and they wanted to ground if you decided
you're going to spend more time
consciously trying to be happier would
you actually become happier they did
this research in the United States in
Taiwan in Russia and in Japan what they
found at first was really odd in the
United States if you try consciously to
make yourself happier you do not become
happier in the other countries if you
try to make your subconscious to become
happier you do and if s they're like
what's going on here can I be what they
discovered was in the United States if
you try to make yourself happier
generally what we do is do something for
yourself right I go shopping I treat
myself I indulge myself like eat
whatever it is but it's me me me it's an
individualistic vision of happiness
exactly in the other countries generally
and of course there were exceptions on
both sides but generally if you try to
make yourself happier you do something
for someone else you say for your
friends your family your community so
while we have an instinctively
individualistic idea of happiness they
have an instinctively collective idea of
happiness turns out a vision of
happiness just doesn't work right like
we said before species the thought like
that would have died out on the
savannahs of Africa and it was striking
to me I spent some time in an Amish
village in Indiana and you know the
Amish I'm not congenial to me in many
ways right and yeah I went there because
they were not welcoming of you know they
were very nice but they you know look
I'm a left-wing gay atheist not having
any pride parades in their village
anytime soon right and yeah there's
always evidence that the Amish have
exceptionally low that was a depression
and anxiety as do generally groups who
live like them like the the Hutterites I
could kind of see why right they they
which is not said there are not serious
problems with the Amish and the way they
lived was there ah but it was very
striking to me and and I think you know
the kids you were talking I just think I
learned a huge amount of the stuff that
I talked about in lost connections I
mother bit chasing the screen from
scientists and experts and so on but
actually one of the places that taught
me the most about what you're saying is
a totally different place so to tell you
the story of it if you want because I
think about it every day so in the
summer of 2011 on a big anonymous
housing project in Berlin a woman called
Maria changose climbed out of her
wheelchair she put a sign in her window
she lived on the ground lived in a
ground-floor apartment and the sign said
something like I got a notice saying I'm
going to be evicted from my apartment
next Friday
so next Thursday night I'm gonna kill
myself now this is a kind of housing
project in a slightly strange places in
the middle of Berlin and when they threw
up the the Berlin Wall they built it
very quickly obviously this was the bit
of West Berlin that kind of jutted into
East Berlin right where they did the war
so it's like a Fang right so if the
Soviets had invaded it would've been the
front line so no one wanted to live
there so the only people who lived there
when the wall was there were three
groups recent Muslim immigrants like
this woman Maria gay men and punk
squatters right and as you can imagine
these three groups look to each other
with some Authority well no one really
knew anyone right and and then the wall
came down and suddenly they've got like
this prime real estate in the middle of
Berlin so everyone's rent was going up
loads of people were being evicted
anyway no one knew this woman people
start to knock on a door and they're
like do you need any help
she'd screw you I don't want any help
I'm gonna kill myself and outside the
apartment some of the people who lived
they didn't know each other started
chatting and one of them had this idea
there's a big thoroughfare that goes
into the center of Berlin that runs
through this project is called kotti bad
idea if we just block the street for a
day on a Saturday
they'd probably be us the media will
probably come there probably let Maria
stay in her apartment maybe there'll be
some pressure for us to
you know and our rents to be kept down
to in this disaster to stop it started
to do it they went and built a barricade
in the middle of the road and Maria was
like well I'm gonna kill myself anyway
I'll let them rule me out so they really
are out there and the media did come and
they interviewed Maria and the other
residents a bit of a fuss and it gets to
the end of the day and the police say
okay you've had your fun take it down
but the people who lived in CATI said
what hang on a minute
you haven't told Maria she gets to stay
and actually we want to rent freeze for
our entire block this whole housing
project so when you give us that we'll
take it down of course they knew the
minute they left the barricade the
police would just tear it down so one of
my favorite people are Katia one of the
punk squatters her name's Tonya Gartner
she was tiny miniskirts even in Berlin
winters she's hardcore Tonya had this in
her apartment she had a clacks any of
those things make a loud noise at
football matches she went and got it
came down and she said okay everyone
what we're gonna do is we could drop a
timetable to man this barricade 24 hours
a day until we get what we want
if the police come to take it down let
off the klaxon and we'll all come down
from our apartments and we'll all stop
them right so people start to sign up to
man the barricade right don't know each
other and Tanya in a tiny little
miniskirt was paired with Maria in her
full day job right and these kind of
pairings were happening all over kotti
and first I think we had only had the
Thursday night shift Tanya and urea
alike we've got nothing to talk about
right what are we going to talk about it
couldn't be more likely so they sit
there through the night barely speaking
first few times as the night went on and
they started to talk they realized I had
something incredibly powerful in common
and Maria told Tanya something she'd
never told anyone
so she come to Berlin when she was 16
from a village in Turkey with her two
young children and she was sent to raise
enough money to send back her husband he
would come and join her after she'd been
in Berlin for a year she got word from
home that her husband had died and she
told Tanya that she'd always told people
that he died of a heart attack actually
he died of tuberculosis which was seen
as like a disease of poverty
so when Tonya told Maria something she
didn't talk about very often she had
come to cotton when she was 15 she'd
been thrown out by her middle class
family she found her way to a [ __ ]
she'd lived there for a little while she
got pregnant they realized they had both
been kind of children with children
themselves in this place that they were
very there where they've been very
frightened they realized that something
really powerful and common these kind of
parents were happening all over kotti
there was a young lad called Mehmet who
kept being there cut nearly throwing him
out of school they said he had ADHD was
paired with this grumpy old white guy he
said he didn't believe in direct action
because he loves Stalin but in this case
he'd make an exception they did a shift
together he the old white guy started
helping Matt with his homework I'm gonna
start doing a lot better and directly
opposite this this housing project
there's a a gay club called zip block
that opened four years before the
protest began and it's run by a guy
alive corporate coach Dean who they're
pretty uncompromising to be a sense of
it the previous place he owned was
called cafe anal there's a lot Muslim
immigrants in this in a Muslim Germans
in this in this in this housing project
when they first open the club there was
a lot of people who were really pissed
off in fact their windows got smashed
but after the protests have been going
for a while it felt very early on the
gay club gave all their furniture to the
protest they were like they gave free
drinks they were like you know after a
while they said you know you guys should
have your meetings in our club we even
the lefties okati were like we're not
going to get these very religious
Muslims to come and you know have their
meetings underneath the posters for
fisting naira it's not going to happen
right actually it did start as one of
the Muslim women they're said to me we
all realize we had to take these small
steps to understand each other after the
protest to be going on for about a year
one day and a man arrived at kotti he
was in his early 50s was cooked it's
called Tong Kai and it's unclear when
you meet some guys got some kind of
cognitive difficulties had been living
homeless but it also has an amazing
energy about him everyone immediately
liked him and after he's there for two
or three days that by this time they had
actually turned that barricade into a
permanent structure in the street and
they stood with a roof and everything
and they said you know you should start
living here we don't want you to be
homeless he started living there he
became a much loved part of the kotti
protest no months later one day the
police came to inspect the
communist-backed every now on them
and tunco doesn't like it when people
argue he thought the police were arguing
so he went to try to hug one of the
officers they thought he was attacking
them so they they arrested him that was
when it was discovered that chung-kai
had been shut away in a psychiatrist
with all a psychiatric hospital often in
a padded cell for twenty years he'd
escaped one day lived on the streets for
a few months and they found his way to
kotti so the police took him back to the
psychiatric hospital and he's put back
in his cell at which point the entire
kotti housing project turned into a kind
of free tonka movement right they
descend on this psychiatric hospital and
the psychiatrists are like what is this
they've got all these like Muslim women
in his jabs these game very camp gay men
and these punks demanding the release of
this person they had shut away for
twenty years
they don't understand it but I remember
early um Canton born one of the
protesters saying to them you know you
don't love him he doesn't belong with
you we loved him he belongs with us I'm
over thinking you know how many of us if
someone Carter does away would have
hundreds of people descending saying no
we love this is it right anyway many
things happened to kotti I mean that's
like a movie ya know it's like that's
like a movie you'd see it Sundance crazy
people coffee because I would turn up
every you know four or five months talk
to them and just burst is to serve
others so movie and then water than say
three once yo hand I think maybe you
have allergies cuz my eyes would water
so anyway so does she get to keep her
apartment and she didn't commit suicide
they got tongue high back they got nerve
I got to stay in her neighborhood they
got a rent freeze for their entire
housing project and they then launched a
referendum initiative to keep rents down
across Berlin got the largest number of
written signatures in the history of the
city of Berlin but the last time I saw
Maria she said to me you know I'm really
glad I got to stay in my neighborhood
that's wonderful I gained so much more
than that you know and she said you know
I'm surrounded by these amazing people
all along and I never knew and I
remember I'm thinking then you know one
of nearest friends another one of the
women who took part in the protest is
this woman called Nariman man care
he's a Turkish gentleman and she said to
me you know when I grew up in in Turkey
I grew up in a village and I called my
whole village home and I came to live in
the Western world and I learned that
what we meant to call home is just our
four walls and then this protest began
and I started to think of this whole
place and all these people as my home
and I realized talking to her that in
some sense in this culture we are
homeless you need to feel you belong the
sense of home we've built is not big
enough for that sense of longing that
the Bosnian writer Alexander Heyman said
home is where people notice when you're
not there right lots of people are
homeless in that sense and I'm gonna
think he's so clearly in kotti think
about how distress these people were
Nuria was about to kill herself
Mehmet kept me nearly thrown out of
school they said he had ADHD
tunk I was shut away in a padded cell
loads of them were depressed and anxious
these people did not need to be drugged
most of them they needed to be together
they needed to have a sense of meaning
and purpose they needed a home and I
remember one time sitting with Noah
Tania outside as a block the gay club
and her saying to me you know when
you're at home and when you're in your
house and you're all alone and you feel
like [ __ ] you think there's something
wrong with you but what we did is we
came out of our corner fighting and we
realized we were surrounded by people
who feel like felt like this and we
realized how strong we could be and to
me it was such an important lesson about
about what's gone wrong and you know the
people are kotti I love those people
they're amazing people but in one sense
they are not exceptional people right
they are ordinary people this was just
beneath the surface it did not take much
for them to see how powerful this could
be and this is just beneath the surface
everywhere this is this is you know I
remember in the run up to the 2016
election being in in West Cleveland with
a group of people who were doing
get-out-the-vote work I was following
four different become right
and we were on one of those streets in
West Cleveland where a third of the
houses have been demolished a third have
been abandoned a third still have people
living in them often behind actual
barbed wire I mean we knocked on one
door and there was a woman if I were to
guess when looking at her was 60 I
realized she was actually the same she
said she was the same age as me I was 37
at the time I was amazed she'd had a
really hard life she was very articulate
extremely angry absolutely refusing to
vote Hillary and she made this this
verbal slip that really stayed with me
she she started the area used to be like
her parents and grandparents and she
meant to say when I was young what she
actually said is when I was alive and it
really knocked me back and I remember
looking at her stream and all these
people hiding behind barbed wire with
all these cameras in front of their
houses they have no money but they've
got enough to buy a camera right and I
thought the solution to what you need is
all around you and you've been cut off
by this culture from seeing it right
you've literally put barbed wire between
you and the people next to you and I
thought about kotti and I thought about
what this woman needed and I and I
thought about the sickness in this
culture that we've been so we've been
we've been driven away from seeing the
solution that's right in front of us do
you know what I mean it's haunting that
story about the woman but I think that
that story about kotti perfectly
encapsulates essentially every facet of
what you talk about it's like this
amazing drama that plays out that
elucidates not only the problem but also
the solution and the simplicity of the
solution and we have to wind this down
because we got to get you to Santa
Monica but I want to leave it on a
little bit of a solution-oriented
optimistic note understanding you know
the the cultural drives that are
compelling so many of us in this
unhealthy direction
contributing to all of these disorders
that we're seeing and intellectually
understanding that the solution is
within arm's reach it's still so
difficult for people to access and we
could tell these stories and you can
inspire people but there's that person
who's listening who's like you don't
understand my pain like that's great but
like I got three kids and I'm super
depressed I can barely get out of bed
and I'm just trying to make it through
the day I don't live in an apartment
building where we can you know block off
the street and have a protest you know
so what are some of the things that that
like where can somebody begin to try to
build community and connection with
others with nature so that they can find
that that hopeful thread that they can
pull on that will shine some light so I
would say two things about that the
first is one of my closest relatives is
a struggling single mom who works every
hour she can to keep her kids in their
apartment and when she gets home she
collapses and is too tired to even watch
television most nights the idea that I
would say to her well your job now is to
democratize your workplace fight for a
universal basic income it would be
grotesque to say that to her right we
don't approach most problems like this
we don't when we have a discussion about
car accidents we don't say well we can't
solve the problem car accidents what do
you say to this person who's just been
mangled on the on the i-95 and is
bleeding in the wreckage right but I'd
say I don't want to talk to that person
I mean I'll call them an ambulance
I very much want to out them let's talk
about how we can change things like by
having speed limits and seat bags as
seatbelts and airbags so it doesn't get
to the point where so many people are
mangled on the own only five right so
the first thing I would say is in a
sense I think the I was totally natural
and right question I wouldn't start at
that point I would say mostly my message
to the person I love him in my family
who's in that position is firstly your
pain makes sense you're not crazy to
feel this way you have been given a
really rough deal
and I will try to love you and be
present with you and help you change
your life and I will try to change the
culture so you are set free to make more
of the changes that you need to make
right so what the person you're talking
about who's trapped in that's it but we
live in a culture where huge numbers of
people are trapped half of Americans
have less than $500 but if a disaster
happens right through no fault of their
own because that money has been
transferred to the rich right the the
six heirs to the Walmart fortune who are
heirs they have done nothing to earn
that money and more than the own more
and have more money than the bottom 100
million Americans right where did your
money go what happened right
so we created a culture where lots of
people are trapped I want to fight to
change the culture so they are no longer
trapped I don't want to give people a
false kind of bromide which is you know
I go through in the book lots of things
people can do some of them are coming
together and fighting for collective
solutions some of the things people can
do on their own and there's a particular
kind of meditation called
loving-kindness meditation that's been
proven to really help I go through other
examples but I don't want to be
misleading about this I don't think
there are very good individualistic
solutions in a society that's falling
apart where Donald Trump is the most
powerful person where people are
profoundly lonely where they've been
taught to value the wrong things where
many be up with it inequality is going
off the scale where they are humiliated
and controlled at work I don't want to
be saying to an individual person hey
here's my little solution for you it
needs a big solution right now there are
smaller things that people can do even
if you're in solitary confinement in a
prison for the rest of your life there
are things you can do of course I don't
want to belittle the possibility of
individuals to do things because there
are individuals they can do but the most
important thing we can do is come
together and that's happening right
there are amazing struggles and they're
not privileged people right think about
the fight for 15 the fight for a higher
minimum wage and mate you know workers
who work in you know McDonald's and
Burger King and jack-in-the-box you know
coming together to fight for a higher
minimum wage a great example which gives
you more time which
gives you more more more of everything
right um there's a whole range of
campaigns happening so I would say the
single most important thing is if you
possibly can and I appreciate something
I can't do this but if you possibly can
get to a group of people who feel like
you who can see that they're upset you
can see they've been that they're
wounded and are seeking a solution
together because partly what I learned
at kotti is the struggle is the solution
right the act of coming together and
saying we've been made to feel like this
through no fault of our own and we can
fight for a solution together and
sometimes there are long fights right
I'm gay the first people to fight for
gay rights in the 1870s that's a long
journey from 1870 to you know that was
Supreme Court decision in 2015
you know the granting equal marriage
rights right that's a long fight but the
act of coming together and fighting for
their own dignity even in 1870 when they
were really early in the fight and they
didn't live to see much progress other
than the dignity that they stood up and
said the problem here isn't with me
right the there is a dignity in
asserting that and showing it to other
people in standing with other people so
I would say wherever possible and there
is nowhere in the United States where
this is not the case where you are not
surrounded by people who feel in a
similar way find those people right we
have tools to find those people even if
all you can do is sit with them for half
an hour a week sit with them if you
possibly can and if you're so wounded
you can't do that okay then help is on
the way the rest of us are going to
understand this problem differently and
if you can't fight for yourself we will
try to fight for you that's powerful no
it's great you know I mean look we could
spend another five hours tough and we
could talk about all manner of things
that that people can do to try to you
know alleviate some of this pain but I
think that's very great very practical
and and powerful advice I mean that's
look essentially that's how that's the
premise of 12-step right which I'm a
member of and it's it's all it's all
about getting together with people that
share a common dilemma and share a
common solution and the struggle is the
solution it is the community that is
created around a shared interest that
that is fundamentally you know it's it's
not about arriving at a future place
that is in and of itself the selves to
the wound I think and a great place to
start so we're gonna let you go I should
just say can my publishers always tell
me off if I don't say this if you would
like any more information about the book
if you would like to know where to get
the book the audiobook if you would like
to take a quiz to see how much you know
about the causes of depression and
anxiety if you would like to listen to
audio of lots of the people we've talked
about what's the other thing there was
tell me to say if you would like to know
what a range of people have said about
the book from Elton John to Hillary
Clinton to Tucker Carlson to having
Tesla brand you got a trait blur I don't
know what's going on in your life but
like you got the coolest people the blur
of your book and by the way I was gonna
do all that for you but continue please
if you don't know any of those things I
just feel like I do stuff like Daiichi
foodies advert here we go
if you go to WWE actions calm it's not
lost connection song because it turns
out there's a [ __ ] band called lost
connections that they were talking about
what I was playing the book out of they
no longer exist
they seem very good I listened to one of
their songs and yeah go W on you can
also find out where to follow me on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram what that
was asked in an interview recently they
said what's your Twitter what's your
facebook and then they said what's your
snapchat and I said I am a 39 year old
man on snapchat
are certainly pedophile habits moment no
one is path exactly and also chasing the
screen and chasing the scream calm or
you get chest and scream calm and other
people said nice things about that as
well yeah what I love about both of
these websites in your books is that as
you mentioned you could go to the sites
and you literally have all of these
inter audio of all these interviews that
you've done with all of these people
so you can listen to the people at Katya
the people are cutting their audio you
can hear how much jokes I get took you
to them yeah yeah you could listen to
audio with all the experts and all these
people have any good things to put out
there and kind of resource people and
how's the depression now how you feel
you look happy you're smiling yeah no I
feel I'm not depressed at all I haven't
been for quite some time although I am
always careful kits caveat that which is
that I was in the privileged position
that I could change my life and in a way
what I'm fighting for is for everyone to
have the opportunity to do that rather
than just going in a kind of simplistic
way hey I did this and you can tick is
like my close relative can't do that at
the moment right I'm fighting so that we
can change the culture so far more
people could be set free to make the
changes that would release them from
depression and anxiety all right well
thank you my friend
all right how you feel good okay thank
you so much thank you come back and talk
to me anytime
all right thanks I might fall Thanks
thank you all right peace
[Music]
you